PROFESSOR: Velocity.
So we assume that we
have an omega of k.
That's the assumption.
There are waves in which, if
you give me k, the wavelength,
I can tell you what is omega.
And it may be as simple
as omega equal to kc,
but it may be more complicated.
In fact, the different waves
have different relations.
In mechanics, omega would be
proportional to k squared.
As you've seen, the energy
is proportional to p squared.
So omega will be
proportional to k squared.
So in general, you
have an omega of k.
And the group velocity is the
velocity of a wave packet--
packet--
constructed--
by superposition of waves.
Of waves.
All right.
So let's do this here.
Let's write a wave packet.
Psi of x and t is going to
be done by superposing waves.
And superposition means
integrals, summing over
waves of different values of k.
Each wave, I will construct
it in a simple way
with exponentials.
ikx minus army of kt.
And this whole thing, I will
call the phase of the wave.
Phi of k.
So that's one wave.
It could be sines or cosines,
but exponentials are nicer.
And we'll do with
exponentials, in this case.
But you superimpose them.
And each one may be superimposed
with a different amplitude.
So what does it mean?
It means that there is a
function, phi of k, here.
And for different
k's, this function
may have different values.
Indeed, the whole assumption
of this construction
is based on the statement
that phi of k peaks.
So phi of k--
as a function of k is
0 almost everywhere,
except a little bump around some
frequency that we'll call k0.
Narrow peak.
That is our wave.
And depending on how
this phi of k looks,
then we'll get a different wave.
We're going to try to identify
how this packet moves in time.
Now--
There is a quick way
to see how it moves.
And there is a way to
prove how it moves.
So let me do, first, the
quick way to see how it moves.
It's based on something
called the principle
of stationary phase.
I doubt it was said to you
in [? A03 ?] in that way.
But it's the most
powerful wave to see this.
And in many ways, the quickest
and nicest way to see.
Takes a little bit of
mathematical intuition,
but it's simple.
And intuition is something that.
I think, you have.
If you're integrating--
a function--
multiplied-- a function, f of x,
multiplied by maybe sine of x.
Well, you have f of
x, then sine of x.
Sine is 1/2 the times positive,
1/2 the times negative.
If you multiply
these two functions,
you're going to get the function
that is 1/2 time positive
and 1/2 the time negative.
And in fact, the integral
will contribute almost nothing
if this function
is slowly varying.
Because if it's slowly varying,
the up peak and the down peak
hasn't changed
much the function.
And they will cancel each other.
So the principle
of stationary phase
says that if you're integrating
a function times a wave,
you get almost no contribution,
except in those places where
the wave suddenly becomes
of long wavelength
and the phase is stationary.
Only when the wave doesn't
change much for a while,
and then it changes again.
In those regions, the function
will give you some integral.
So that's the principle
of stationary phase.
And I'll say it here,
I'll write it here.
Principal--
of stationary phase.
We're going to use that
throughout the course.
Phase.
And I'll say the following.
Since--
phi anyway only
peaks around k0--
This is the principle of
stationary phase applied
to this integral.
Since-- since only for
k roughly equal to k0.
The integral--
has a chance--
To be non-zero.
So here is what I'm saying.
Look.
The only place where this
integral contributes-- it
might as well integrate
from k0 minus a little delta
to k0 plus a little delta.
Because this whole
thing vanishes outside.
And if we're going to integrate
here, over this thing,
it better be that this wave
is not oscillating like crazy.
Because it's going
to cancel it out.
So it better stop
oscillating there
in order to get
that contribution,
or send in another way.
Only when the phase stops,
you get a large contribution.
So on the phase stops varying
fast with respect to k.
So you need-- need--
that the phase
becomes stationary--
with respect to k, which is
the variable of integration--
at k0.
So around k0, better be that the
phase doesn't change quickly.
And the slower it changes,
the better for your integral.
You may get something.
So if you want to
figure out where
you get the most
contribution, you
get it for k around
k0, of course.
But only if this thing
it's roughly stationary.
So being roughly stationary
will give the following result.
The result is that
the main contribution
comes when the phase, phi of k,
which is kx minus omega of kt,
satisfies the condition
that it just doesn't vary.
You have 0 derivative at k0.
So the relative
with respect to k
is x minus d omega of
k dk at k0 t must be 0.
Stationary phase.
Function phase has
a stationary point.
Look what you get.
It says there that you
only get a contribution
if this is the case.
So the value of x, where you
get a big bump in the integral,
and the time, t, are
related by this relation.
The hump in this packet will
behave obeying this relation.
So x is equal to d
omega dk at k0 t.
And it identifies the packet
as moving with this velocity.
x equal velocity times times.
This is the group velocity.
End of the answer
by stationary phase.
Very, extremely simple.